i am vengeance i am the knight
i am a little bit mixed on the stuff
that came out of dc fandom to be honest
[Music]
hey everybody so yeah extra video this
week because
well because dc fandom
now i did do a video on dc tail end of
last week because before talking about
anything that went on the
event i did feel the need to bring
attention to the
massive firings of pretty much the
entire editorial staff and the
cancellation of a whole bunch of books
over at dc comics itself
especially because it felt like warner
brothers was really hoping that that
would be completely drowned out by stuff
coming out of dc fandom indeed it did
but i got that off my chest i have
reminded you now so that i can sleep at
night and feel okay so let's talk about
what they actually did
drop at this thing now this is not going
to be a comprehensive list of
everything that was talked about but i
am going to go over the major stuff i.e
trailers i'll touch on some of the other
things as i remember them
so if i don't bring something up it's
because it didn't stick in my head
i'm human and lazy so
let's start with the big one which would
be the trailer for
zack snyder's justice league now before
i talk about the trailer they did also
confirm that this is going to be
released as a
four part miniseries an hour a piece or
a total of
four hours for this thing which
first off can i can i just
can i just say that the fact that this
is being touted as
the snyder cut is feeling a little bit
dubious and i'll explain
why four hours is about the length that
you'd expect out of
a first pass cut
even if he had stayed on the project
they
never would have allowed him to
produce a four-hour long film so
what we're going to get isn't actually
the movie we would have gotten in
theaters
had zack snyder been allowed to finish
it
we're basically getting the extra
expanded edition i suppose is the best
way to put it
but it it is odd to me that they're not
holding it to a theatrical standard like
they would have actually
done if he had stayed on the film
originally
but then again i guess they granted him
the ultimate cut on batman v superman so
i suppose there's precedent
anyways let me be upfront about the fact
that i am not the target audience
for this thing i
i'm not in or down for snyder's take on
these characters for the most part i'm
just not
i don't think snyder is a bad director i
don't think he was even necessarily a
bad choice
but his version of what this universe
and these
characters are is not something i
really wanted so i will actually say
that for the most part this
sells what it ha what it is pretty well
what it's selling is not something i am
personally
all that interested in buying i'll
probably still see it out of morbid
curiosity
but it does a pretty solid job
it communicates the mood that i would
expect
out of the finished product and a mood
that is distinct from the film that we
got in theaters there's a lot of footage
that
is that was not in the theatrical cut so
they're really showing off some of
the extra stuff there including you know
stuff that was in
early trailers that was clearly cut from
joss whedon's version of the film
in addition to some stuff that clearly a
lot of cgi work has already been done on
with in
shots of things like dark side and the
uh
i guess original conception of
steppenwolf
that being said i did roll my eyes and
go oh are you freaking
kidding me over the music
selection
snyder should know better than to use
that
song because the last time he dabbled
with that song
in his watchman film like that was the
one moment where even people i
know who really liked that movie still
mock
that moment where it was used there it's
a very on the nose selection
it's not for what the song is actually
about it was actually appropriate for
it's used in watchmen even though that
was
um it feels very inappropriate here in
terms of what the song is
standardly supposed to be about and it
feels very
self-congrat if well especially
considering it's halloween possibly even
literally feels like preaching to the
choir
your savior zack snyder has come
it just feels so self-indulgent
and i normally wouldn't hammer on this
too hard except snyder himself is
he's really gone all in
on this stuff and like somebody brought
my attention to a
reply he did to something on twitter and
i'll put
his tweet up here but he basically went
if you don't like what i'm doing it's
because you're a child
like really dude
it honestly
it's become one of those things that
even if
the snyder cut is good i feel like it's
something that's going to be soured for
me
by the fandom well before that
kind of the way that over time i kind of
soured on firefly from
from some of the fandom on that star
wars fandom has definitely
soured me on on some stuff like and i i
don't like that
especially in the case of this where
like at least with firefly and star wars
that was a fandom i was actively in
and that kind of went in a direction i
was like
um but like something like this fandom
that i have no part of
is still turning me off this and
it feels like he's just really feeding
into
that the the snyder cup people and like
that makes sense to a degree
it's arguable that they and their online
campaign
and support was the reason this happened
so i get it
but it does it feels less like thank you
so much for helping me get this done it
feels much more like
yes i am great and mighty and my
faithful
shall be rewarded it feels high on
himself
right now with this and that's that's
turning me off a little bit
kind of a little bit how todd phillips
talking about the joker
movie i i had issues with that film
regardless but that kind of soured me a
bit with him talking about how it's a
real movie and this is like oh for god's
sake
anyways like i said it's a pretty
competently and decently put together
trailer
it and it feels like it's probably going
to be accurate to what the thing is
so my issues aside it's a pretty good
trailer
and if you are one of the people who was
actively looking forward to the snyder
cut
it probably really landed for you so i i
can't really critique it other than
other than the music choice and sort of
critiquing the vibe around
around it but you know
i am going to try and eventually assess
the movie
separate from all that we'll see if i'm
capable i am only human
what else we got okay so the wonder
woman trailer
it looked good and fun it was consistent
with the first one but then
then they gave us a look at cheetah and
i will be honest cheetah was the one
thing um that i was i've been most
skeptical about
going into this for two reasons
one is she's the kind of villain that
i'm not sure is going to
work in the types of stories that they
usually do in superhero
movies she's a very personal she's a
very one-on-one kind of villain
which doesn't lend itself to the larger
epic scale and scope
that they usually like to have for
superhero stories in movies
um that's not to say that she can't be
made to work i was also
uh somewhat skeptical of the casting i
am not a particularly big fan of kristen
wiig
um and that having been said
the bits of her that we saw in this
trailer when she is
still human i'm actually i feel like i'm
gelling
with what she's doing and i think she
might even be able to do it well then we
got the images of cheetah like as
cheetah
and first off it really felt like they
were it felt like they were
simultaneously trying to show off
what this looked like but also hide it
because it's
really dark and it's hard to make out
clearly
but man did it make me think of cats and
like part of that's not this thing's
fault it didn't
when they were shooting this they didn't
know cats was gonna be
cats but i'm not feeling this
all cgi fur thing
i'm just not i wish they'd come up with
a with a practical suit
or something you know modified with cgi
but it it
it looks mocap it doesn't look great so
that has me a little um
but other i i hope it doesn't drag the
movie down and to be fair
like if that is something that doesn't
happen until the climax the climax of
the first film
first wonder woman was the weakest part
of that movie so
i guess that'll just be the consistent
problem
with wonder woman movies um
they dropped stuff about a couple of
video games there
was gotham knights which i'm
like my interest is purely academic kind
of in terms of like oh i wonder
you know what what the story will
because i don't have a current gen
gaming system um i don't i mean god
we're heading into another new
generation i'm definitely not going to
be down
on the ground floor of that so my
interest in that stuff is fairly minimal
but it was kind of nice that they showed
it off a bit
there was the suicide squad roll call
um sort of trailer thing where we got
the full list of all the characters
and actors who are in this and we also
found out
who the villain's gonna be and my god
james gunn
you wonderful madman
so first of all this cast is huge
which to me says two things one we're
gonna have a lot more of them
die on mission which they should
the fact that only one character tokenly
died in the first one and it was super
obvious if you were paying attention at
all
who it was going to be i was like what
the hell ever
whereas here i'm hoping that they will
you know have it will be much harder to
predict
who's going to die and who's going to
live and with a
cast this big they can pick off a lot
more of them
and the other thing that they're really
leaning into is the idea that the
suicide squad is usually made up of c
and d
listers so we've got people like the
thinker peter capaldi match
uh and the weasel and rat catcher 2 and
polka dot man and
nathan fillion is playing arm fall off
boy
[Laughter]
oh that makes me so happy and then in
addition
we found out who the villain's going to
be the villain is going to be starro
the conqueror now if you don't know your
comic book lore
starro is a character with actually a
little bit of prestige to him he was the
first villain
that the justice league as a team ever
fought
he's also a psychic
starfish from space and if it was any
one of the james gunn
directing this thing i would immediately
be going uh
but i mean he made ego the living planet
work
so hey why not
i will still say it gives me a little
bit of concern because star of the
conqueror is a large global style
threat and that was one of the big
fundamental
issues with the first suicide squad is
you don't call the suicide squad to deal
with a threat to the planet
you assemble the suicide squad for
something that is
dangerous but doesn't warrant like
legitimate superheroes
and if we're dealing with starro unless
they really change his mo
um then i i don't
feel like the suicides it's it's too
grand a threat it's too
large scale uh a mission
for the suicide squad although i suppose
it's possible that they'll initially get
dispatched on something smaller and
it'll snowball
into dealing with him maybe i don't know
um but i have a lot of faith in james
gunn taking this on
so that helps uh then we've got
uh a few things that we learned about
don't worry i'm getting to the batman
trailer we'll save that for the end
um aquaman two they're still working on
shazam's two they're still working on
there was sort of an animatic uh kind of
thing released for black adam
as a as a tease i mean it was kind of
nice just to get it confirmed that black
adam's
still a thing that they are aware they
said they were gonna do
a bit like the flash um movie it is one
of those things like i'll believe it
when i see on-set photos of them
actually filming it
until then i'm kind of a little
skeptical that it's ever going to
actually happen just because they've
been talking about it for so long with
no real forward movement
but they did present something which is
more than they've done up to this point
because up to this point they've just
sort of said yeah the rock will be black
adam
anything else no no that's it
we got a little bit more of a sense of
feel and tone from this like
that was it and it's an animatic so it's
not it's not something that they're
necessarily committed to
in terms of doing it that way but you
know
it's something that that was kind of
neat
let's talk about the batman trailer
which was the other one
in addition to zack snyder's justice
league which is kind of the big
thing there are some things that
i'm intrigued by there are some things
that i'm on board for there are some
things that i'm like
i don't know so
let's start with robert pattinson as
batman
first off i kind of get a kick out of
the fact that
they're acknowledging he's got a bunch
of really dark makeup around his eyes
you know to darken his eyes under the
mask because it always did throw me off
in things like the original batman you
can clearly see on any close-up that
this has all been blacked
all around here but it takes the the
cowl and the mask off and i'm like no
it's not there so
i kind of like that they just
acknowledge that he's just
got this smeary black eye shadow all
around
um so there's that i don't love
the loose floppy hair i don't know why i
always think of
bruce wayne with a bit more of a tamed
haircut
i guess that's a that's an aesthetic
thing that doesn't really matter um
i i did like the first image we got of
him just kind of standing here in him
movie he has
this intimidating stance
uh just way of holding himself when he's
in the suit
that i saw that i'm digging that i'm
feeling that
so i'm really mixed on the
bit where he beats up somebody
on the one hand i like that it's a
continuous cut
and it is a hard-hitting bit of action
like those hits hurt and that's
generally what i ask for in any action
scene
the hits should hurt
the problem is even though it's well
executed and well done and
works my problem is i'm kind of sick of
brutal batman i'm kind of over it
you know bale was on the edge of that
and then
the affleck batman really leaned into
that
and it's a little bit disappointing
especially
seeing that in a first trailer knowing
that the riddler
appears to be the main villain here and
the riddler is someone to tax
batman's his abilities as a detective
as opposed to someone who just beats
people up not that i like don't like a
good batman action scene but
like i feel like we haven't really
properly had him
being a detective on screen i was kind
of looking forward to this
doing that and so it makes me nervous
that the
most focused bit on batman we get is
this
now to be fair they had only shot about
25 percent of this movie before
they had to shut down production because
the plague hit
so it's distinctly possible that this
scene
is not necessarily representative of
most of what batman is going to be doing
it just happens to be something that
they had already shot so they kind of
had to stick it in because they've only
got so much footage to work with
that's a distinct possibility and so
that's sort of my asterisks on this
criticism
that you know they may not have the more
detective-y stuff to be able to put in a
trailer
yet uh jeffrey wright as gordon
i'm down for that i am very curious
to find out more about this riddler
about paul danos
riddler they're they seem to be going
for kind of a
almost a john doe from seven um or
jigsaw killer
kind of thing with him which
like it part of me says like that's just
grittying up the riddler in a way that
is the most obvious way to do it
except that you know the only riddler
we've had
on the big screen so far was jim
carrey's campy riddler which i
actually like i actually think he was
good for that part
but you know what let's have a serious
take on the riddler
i'm okay with that especially because i
feel like
we kind of got my ideal balance of the
riddler from gotham
in terms of balancing the hum a
homicidal nature with the need to
riddle people and so i
since i already feel like i have that
i'm a little bit more willing to be like
okay
you want to go a little bit further on
this end on the
on the dark and the deranged end for
this one okay
i've got my balanced version of the
riddler fairly recently
let's see what you do on this far end
i'll take a look
so that's just kind of where i am uh
obviously the film's very
dark visually huge shock batman is dark
edgy um we hear a little bit of andy
serkis as
alfred which i'm down for um i dig that
again to compare to gotham he he his
voice
has that same sort of slightly dirtier
uh
vibe that um that sean pertwee brought
so it i don't mean to overly compare it
to gotham but it does kind of feel like
it's it's taking a few cues from that in
a way that i
like especially as a fan of gotham so
yeah this trailer was pretty successful
especially knowing like how little the
film is actually shot and how little
footage they would have had to work with
to put this together in the first place
i am
intrigued um to see what else we get
that's kind of it for me on this it was
a
decently put together presentation all
things considered
there was a i think the suicide squad
trailer was the thing i was the most
overwhelmingly positive towards
um everything else i like i had a note
here or there about
but it was this was pretty well put
together
and uh yeah props to them on on
presenting it well and having
some decent stuff to show off we'll see
how much of it pans out
uh how much of it ends up being as good
as they're making it look now
but what are your thoughts on the
various things from dc fandom the
trailers the announcements
anything i failed to talk about because
obviously there was plenty of other
stuff that went on that i either touched
on very lightly or didn't touch on at
all
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments
let's talk about it a bunch of stuff to
do you know what it is like
share subscribe and all those things and
i have links to
merch other social media etc etc i have
a patreon which
is what enables me to keep the lights on
around here
but you also don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you're the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh